-Our guest tonight is an
Emmy-winning actor you know from
shows such as "The Office," "The
Practice," and "Boston Legal."
He stars in the ninth season
of "The Blacklist,"
which returns to NBC on
Thursday, October 21st.
Let's take a look.
-During the past two years,
I've learned what to hold on to
and what to let go of.
If I look at that, if I come
back even once...
I fear all that work
will be for nothing.
There would be names
to be taken,
people would be held
accountable.
Down the line,
things would get very dark.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend James Spader.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, welcome back.
-Thank you.
Fred's lockdown was
so different from...
-I know, right?
-...anyone else's that I've --
-I feel like one of the things
a lot of people did in lockdowns
was forget people's birthdays.
-Yeah.
-And it seemed like Fred
really managed --
-But he was also going into
crowded places.
Like, the doctor's office
had tons of patients.
-Can you imagine going to
a doctor's office
twice in 10 days?
-He's like going for --
He's going to the sub shop.
There's tons of people there.
-Yeah, you were doing
a lot of being out there.
-I was busy.
[ Laughter ]
-So, this is --
I'm actually fascinated.
I want to ask you something.
Because we've had guests on
this week who I had interviewed
during the pandemic via Zoom,
but you actually were here
in January in this studio
without an audience.
-Yes.
-How -- Do you remember
what that was like for you?
Did you think it was weird
being in this big studio
with nobody here?
-I really have no memory of it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You're kind of a reverse Fred
in that way.
-I guess.
[ Laughter ]
Really, I have no memory of it
at all.
-I can tell you this.
Hopefully you have some memory
of being here.
You have been on the show now
11 times.
-11 times.
-That's really --
The other thing,
because I remember --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. 11 times. That's great.
This show and "The Blacklist"
started the same year.
You were actually out here.
-And boy, have things
gone downhill.
[ Laughter ]
-Right? We don't even have
labels on the water anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Can you believe you've been
doing the show
as long as you have?
-It is a long time.
Ninth season.
-Yeah. I noticed from the clip
you had a shaved head.
-I did.
-Is that a bald cap
or did you actually --
-No, no, no,
it was a shaved head.
-So you did it?
-Yeah.
-Alright.
-I mean, it isn't that much
further than this.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, how long did it take
to grow back?
-It's just a couple more passes
really, you know?
Yes, this year starts -- this
season starts two years later,
and he was, you know, sort of
lost for a couple of years
and came down with
terrible mange and so...
[ Laughter ]
Terrible hot spots.
-Oh, yeah.
And they had to get rid of it.
-So he just had to get rid
of all it.
Yuck, and start over.
-You've always talked
on this show admiringly
about the writers on
"The Blacklist"
and how they continue to be
inventive and not just keep it
fresh for the audience
but for you.
Does that continue to be true?
Are you still excited to see
where they're going to take it?
-Yes. No, it's completely
self-serving in that --
You know, but, in all
seriousness, I mean,
that really was what I think
you have to look for in material
that you're going to be doing
for a television show,
especially if it seems like
something that you want to
stick with for a little bit.
And I read the pilot of this,
and it was clear that
there was so -- you know,
the landscape was pretty broad
and the tone was very...
you know, at turns was
very irreverent and funny
and at other times
incredibly intense.
And I realized that
this character really
could go anywhere and you could
take so many twists and turns
and surprises,
and it still continues to.
-This is not your first foray
into television.
You were on "The Office,"
we mentioned.
You were also on "Boston Legal,"
where one of your costars,
Bill Shatner...
-Went to space.
-...went to outer space.
Of your costars in your career,
would he have been
your first choice to send?
-I think he'd be one of --
I think he might be one of --
I think was the best-suited.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Really, I mean, he really was,
besides that great suit
he was wearing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He did let you -- Right.
It was --
I think for most men his age...
-Yes.
-...if you put them in
that suit, it would be jarring.
And yet with him, it looked like
that's what he should
always be wearing.
-Yeah, no, I hope he kept it.
And if he did, I'm sure it'll
show up on his website.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll be right back with more
from James spader.